Well it started as a US DOD effort,
at or the orange book, then with time
multiple countries sort of recognized
this importance of software procurement,
they had to worry about security
that they can evaluate for
those software products.
That evolved into what's called
the Common Criteria which is Is
an international standard.
Common Criteria came from efforts
in Europe, in Canada, and
the US one that we talked about.
The idea Is that you are consumer of
the system or user of the system,
you're going to specify what needs you
have or what requirements you have.
Vendor going to sort of
implement a solution and
going to make claims about that solution
meeting your needs or your requirements.
And in particular, we're talking about
sort of security requirements or
security properties.
So whoever is going to evaluate is
going to determine whether the vendor
actually, the claims that they make
are claims that you can believe.
And these claims actually
allow you to say,
well, my needs that I
had specified are met.
So there's three entities, you have
some requirements, a vendor who provides
the solution makes a certain set of
claims how they meet those requirements,
and somebody who evaluates has
to then assess those claims,
and the reason we should be able to
trust whatever those claims are about.
Based on that, we're going to
give it an assurance level,
which rates the trustworthiness
of the systems.
Evaluation assurance level or
EAL, we will be
able to use that to rate a system,
in particular, how well
it meets the claims about security
properties that are important to us.
So similar to division D,
we said, basically,
it didn't do very much EAL1 is
the most basic one and EAL7 is
the most rigorous or the highest level
of trustworthiness that you can get.